top White House officials are rushing to
boost the veep's Rock Bottom approval
ratings fearing the people tank Biden's
2024 chances some of the moves to pump
her up include dramatic slow walking in
Biden's campaign video
featuring her prominently on his website
look at that and schedule the events
with Harris that promote popular
Democratic causes Obama's former top
advisor says they better reboot Kamala
quickly
Kamala Harris is going to have a
prominent place in this campaign because
of his age they need to strengthen her
as a as a a player in all of this I
think there's a real focus on trying to
lift her up here because people are
going to ask like who's your backup
Happy Easter
the reason to Hype up Kamala is the
effort to hide Biden the media calls it
a quote quiet re-election strategy and
they definitely don't want Joe to answer
tough questions like this
you've said questions about your age are
legitimate and your response is always
just watch me but the country is
watching and recent polling shows that
70 of Americans including a majority of
Democrats believe you shouldn't run
again every bloody running from
reelection in this time has been in the
same position there's nothing new about
that you're making it sound like Biden's
really underwater
and number one number two when the same
polling data asks whether they think
what kind of job I've done it gets
overwhelmingly positive results with
regard to age I can't even say I guess
how old I am I can't even say the number
I've done I've done register with me do
you know Charlie and there was a hope in
uh 2020 that she would balance the
ticket you know and it turns out they're
right her loopy incompetence balances
his musty senility he's she's the
insurance policy against the 25th
Amendment yes exactly yeah no and and of
course they had to go they had to search
far and wide to find somebody more
buffoonish than Joe Biden himself and uh
and they wanted to get somebody that
wasn't going to outshine him and they
succeeded
um you know oftentimes these elections
they they really pop when both sides
wind up wanting the same thing to be Pro
a prominent issue and if if Democrats
want Kamala Harris to be a prominent
issue so do Democrats I mean so do
Republicans and it's going to be and I
don't think it's going to I don't think
I don't think Democrats are going to win
that that fight but but I think it's
really interesting that a lot of our
supporters are are you know they're
grateful that the White House is now
focusing on Kamala Harris but the only
reason they're focusing on Kamala Harris
is because they now view the White House
Now views her as a drag on the ticket
which doesn't seem to be it's not like
they're they're doing it out of the
kindness of their heart but this is what
happens and I hate to go here but it's
true if you're playing identity politics
and you pick her because she checks a
couple of the boxes on identity politics
you can't be surprised that she's
incompetent because you didn't look at
competency when you picked her see I
disagree with you I I don't think you
hated to go there
but you know you made me think that like
if they picked Kamala because she's
inferior to Joe Biden as a VP how will
they ever get a VP for Kamala yes
because it's just going to keep getting
worse and worse and worse they can get
Dylan Mulvaney oh there you go and it
would be don't don't put that out it's a
great idea that's a great idea Dana
um can she be fixed they act like she's
a broken computer they think that they
could just turn her off or unplug her
and then plug her back in I think we're
on our ninth reset of Kamala Harris and
I thought it was pretty interesting the
Articles this morning to find out she
has not had a communications director
for several months that's a very coveted
job you want to White House comms
director for the vice president of the
United States and who wouldn't want that
job turns out nobody wants the job I
also think that they've realized that
Republicans will
let's see if they can communicate it
well but imagine the ad that says
if Joe Biden wins every single day for
the next four years could be kamala's
Inauguration Day
and get that swirling around because I'm
not saying that people vote because of a
vice presidential choice they usually
have a very limited amount of effect on
a ticket that could be very different
this year
um
I also feel like
they're trying to talk her up so
axelrod's like Yep they're playing hurt
but we're only halfway through the
season and we're gonna make it through
and they're gonna be fine and we're
going to win in the end you could do an
ad and count how many heartbeats closer
to the presidency
Ronald Harris is now one you know uh do
we have a we have a call for I believe
uh it's one of her uh latest words oh
pretty good do we have that up and ready
all right then let's roll it Sean geez
I think it's very important as you have
heard from so many incredible leaders
for us at every moment in time and
certainly this one to see the moment
in time in which we exist in our present
and to be able to contextualize it to
understand where we exist in the history
and in the moment as it relates not only
to the past but the future it was
interesting you were actually crying
Jessica you were crying you that you
were moved by it
uh that's your vice president that's
your party you must be ashamed of
yourself it's all of our vice presidents
I am not she's not my vice president
yeah this is a joke yeah no I got it
that's I made my like Greg your joking
face but that could be serious
um
the time talking is not ideal we've had
a passage of time incident before and it
go it goes on too long
that was not her most coherent of
comments but
every moment that Democrats spend doing
this they're not focusing on Republicans
and that's what we're up against
everyone knew that Joe Biden was going
to announce a question of whether it was
going to be April 25th or June 20
whatever it was we knew it was happening
we knew that he wasn't pushing her off
the ticket either that was another I
mean how many people anonymously a
couple of Congress people actually went
on record talking about it but otherwise
it was just all this right all the time
like everyone wants to complain to their
favorite reporter about this or that but
we knew that this was going to be the
ticket and this ticket has been hugely
successful and that gets lost in all of
this so they won in 2020 the most votes
collected in American history then in
2022 the Democrats had a far better
night than anyone ever expected and the
issue that sealed the deal in terms of
Democrats winning was the issue of
abortion and she was the face of rolling
back of reproductive right I know it was
weird to station to Facebook
no but when she there were complaints
about you know she got the border which
is a completely thankless portfolio to
get that she was supposed to work on the
Voting Rights bill which was basically
down on arrival they said okay we have a
female vice president it is important to
be talking about this and she toured the
country she did some of her best
interviews on this on this issue and how
pivotal it was going to be and Democrats
overperformed
so I get it that it's fun to make fun of
her for you guys not for me but there's
no indication that she's actually a drag
on this ticket whatsoever or that we
would lose in 2024 the guy who's
probably going to be on the other side
has been indicted
what you think
well I I haven't seen her give any
speech that was forceful and good and
you know I'm thrilled that you played
her last uh Speech where she talks about
we're in the moment and we have to exist
and and look at it and feel it I don't
know what the hell she's talking about
whenever she opens her mouth and you
know what her poll numbers are lower
than Joe's poll numbers so I understand
why they feel the need to keep her given
that she was picked because of identity
politics but yeah I don't understand why
there's so much power between those two
because the Democrats don't want Joe to
run okay and they don't like him and
they don't like her and yet nobody is
coming up and saying you know I'm going
to push my way in there I'm going to
primary him why is there so much power
in that couple and I don't deny what
you're saying about the fact that 2022
wasn't as significant as we thought but
the woman is an embarrassment she goes
on the world stage and she's an
embarrassment she is not prepped and
let's assume she's prepped I think she
doesn't have the comms director because
she's tried them all and they've all
quit but aside from that I mean she
doesn't put the time or the work in to
focus on the issues enough to
communicate to the public that she is
not only capable but she's interested in
the job this is like Escape for her she
says as little and does as little as she
can she got voting rights she got the
Border what has she done nothing I don't
care how difficult they are get out
there and do something but that's not
what she's doing social skate and you
know we'll see what happens in the
election but I think she's an
embarrassment I wonder Brian Kilmeade I
want you to do me a favor I want you to
click to subscribe to the Fox News
YouTube page this is the only way that I
know for sure that you're not going to
miss any great commentary any great news
bites any great interviews coming your
way on Fox you can get it all here on
YouTube so subscribe right now